hey what's up guys it's Rob and welcome
to my tutorial for thee long glider
I'm eager so today I'm going to show you
how to make two different gliders one is
called the bomb glider and I call it
that because it involves making a
waterbomb base the cool thing about this
plane is that it's actually a trick
plane you can actually fold the wings
and bend them up in such a way that the
plane can do flips do spins and actually
come back to you if you throw it right
the other plane is called the eagle and
this is a really nice flying glider as
well I know I've been away for quite a
while on hiatus I'm not going to go into
that now but maybe a little bit at the
end of the video and I might have a
separate update video as well for now I
know you guys want to learn something
new and have a new tutorial so without
further ado let's get started
we could start out with an
eight-and-a-half by eleven letter size
paper and I'm going to be showing you
how to make the bomb glider first if
you'd like to learn how to make the
Eagle first then you can go to this time
here on the bottom we're going to hold
the eight and a half by eleven letter
size paper in a portrait orientation and
then take the left side edge and fold it
across to the right side edge make sure
that the edges are aligned perfectly and
once they're aligned you can just hold
it there on the right side bring your
finger across and then give that paper a
nice crease up and down the left side
you can also run your fingernail against
it gently to make sure that crease is
extra sharp then you can unfold the
paper and you'll see you have a vertical
line that runs up and down the paper
we're now going to take the upper left
corner of the paper and we're going to
fold it so that the top edge here is
aligned with the right side edge just
like you would to make the paper into a
square like I do in my other videos
again once the edges are aligned just
hold it there and then you increase the
upper left portion of the paper and
again run your fingernail against it
open up the paper now you're going to do
the same with the right side take the
upper right corner of the paper
and bring it down so that this top edge
is aligned completely with the left side
edge okay so when you open it you'll
notice that we have an X in the paper
and we also have that vertical line that
runs down the middle of the paper as
well so what we're going to do now is if
you remember how to make the waterbomb
base we then take the edge of the paper
and fold it down to the other edge so
take the top edge of the paper and fold
it down until you see this diagonal line
it's going to basically overlap
perfectly with these diagonal lines okay
so basically we're just taking the X and
folding just the X in half
and if you did it correctly you'll
notice that I basically have a triangle
here and the point should be right on
the edge of the paper
okay so when you open it you basically
have a horizontal line that goes through
the middle of the X okay make sure that
the crease is nice and sharp then we're
going to basically make the waterbomb
base from this portion lift up the right
side of the paper like this and you're
going to tuck this edge into the middle
tuck it in and you'll see you have a
flap here okay all you need to do is
just push down on that and flatten it
out do the same with the left side you
might have to pop the paper out if it
gets a little caught like that but it
should fold directly on those creases
that you made previously when you're
done you should have something that
looks like this and this is basically
the waterbomb base except it has this
extra piece of paper on the bottom okay
so you have the two top flaps and the
two bottom flaps which are attached to
the rest of the paper now that we have
the waterbomb base we're going to take
the top of the triangle and fold it down
to this edge of the paper here directly
in the middle you might have to round it
off a little bit right there because
it's kind of thick fold it down and when
the tip is on the edge just give it a
nice crease on the top
okay so now if you take a look here
you'll notice that inside the tip here
we have a pocket here on the right side
and we have a pocket here on the left
side what we're going to do is we're
going to take both of these little flaps
or tips here and we're going to tuck
them in there so to do that we're going
to take this edge and align it with this
edge by folding the paper in half along
this vertical line here like this give
it a nice crease on the right side you
could do the same with the left side and
then you can give it a little fold up
along this edge here just like that
unfold it do the same with the left side
then what you can do is you can open the
pocket on the right side give this a
little Bend and tuck that tip of the
corner into that pocket right there and
then you could flatten it out do the
same with the left side
okay might not go in all the way that's
not a big deal okay something like that
then you can flatten it out okay now
what you're going to do is you're going
to fold the plane in half along this
vertical line away from you so you're
going to basically give it a mountain
fold along the vertical line right here
like this okay give it a good crease on
the base here so you have something like
that we're going to fold the wings down
and the way that we do this is we're
going to fold this part right here in
half so you're going to fold right about
there and you'll see this part of the
paper should meet up with the very
bottom of the paper here so all you need
to do is to fold this in half like this
by rounding it off and you'll see that
it should meet up with the bottom right
there okay do the same with the other
side
okay then what I like to do is I like to
just hold this part right here and you
can crease these two top parts gently
the top of the wings gently so that they
kind of line up together and then do it
a little bit harder like that
and that's the basic design of the
glider now there's different ways to
make the wings become more stable
stabilization and I'm going to show you
that after I show you how to make the
other plane the Eagle is another pretty
simple glider to make again we're going
to use a eight and a half by eleven
letter size paper and you're going to
take the left side and fold it across to
the right side just like we do with the
other one and in most paper airplane
models line up the edges and make a
crease along the left side there and
we're going to unfold it and we're going
to take both of the top corners and fold
them into the middle so that the top
edge here is aligned with that vertical
line should have something that looks
like this now we're going to fold the
tip of the top of the plane here down to
the edge here so just fold it down
and give it a crease on top so that it
looks like that then you could unfold it
and now we're going to take this whole
triangular portion of the plane and
we're going to fold it down so we're
basically going to make a crease
downwards along this edge of the paper
here this line made by these two edges
of the paper so just fold down the plane
along this edge and then make a crease
on the top now what we're going to do is
we're going to take these two top
corners and we're going to fold it so
that the point here the corner goes
right into the intersection made by this
crease and the vertical line so I'm
going to fold it in until the point of
the corner there lies right there on the
intersection and then give it a crease
on the right side do the same with the
left side now what we're going to do is
we're actually going to fold the point
right here upwards again until it
basically hits against the edges here so
right about here just like that fold it
up and it should kind of lock these two
corners in place and give it a nice
crease on the bottom now we're going to
take the top of the plane and we're
going to fold three-quarters of an inch
down just like that
and then you're going to make a crease
on the top now you might have to just
hold everything down and wreak Reese
this edge here and re crease the other
edge because when you fold down the top
it kind of pushes the paper a little bit
okay
so just make sure everything's nice and
flat basically now you can fold the
whole plane down away from you on the
vertical line okay and now what we're
going to do is we're going to take the
top edge here of the wing and you're
going to align it with the bottom here
and then give it a nice crease along the
top of the wing here
now you could do the same with the other
side fold it down might want to round it
off here again my little edge here got a
little crumpled and there you go now you
have the Eagle which again we can add
some stabilization and we have the bomb
glider so throw the bomb lighter there's
a lot of different ways you can throw it
and configure the wings if you just
leave it the way it is right after you
finish folding it'll fly but it won't
exactly have the stability that it will
if you adjust the wings so just throwing
it like that in the bowl if you just
take it right after you fold it and fold
the wings down like this and leave them
fold it down and you throw it it'll kind
of do some spins in the air now for some
stabilization and adjustments to the
wing what you want to do to do the basic
stabilization is to take each of the
wings and you're going to fold the edge
up about a half of an inch like that and
then make a good crease so that it looks
something like this and it's vertically
inclined do the same with the other wing
by folding it up about a half of an inch
and now you'll notice that it should
have more stabilization when it flies a
couple things that you can do though
play around with it one of them is to
take the corners of the wings and to
fold them up like this so that the plane
looks something like this this will
actually make it turn a little bit some
other things you can try is just taking
the wings and folding one up like this
maybe like an inch or so folding the
other side down
as far as the Eagle is concerned there's
not really many tricks you can do with
it but right if you fold it it'll
actually glide pretty well just like
that
so again just hold it by here and just
throw it really gently as far as
stabilization is concerned with the
Eagle I found that it's better if you
fold the ends of the wings down about
1/2 1/2 an inch like that and then you
can throw it gently
thank you guys very much for watching my
tutorial for the BOM glider and also the
eagle if you did enjoy these rate by
clicking the buttons down below and also
if you're not already subscribed please
click the subscribe button above or
below wherever it is now I don't even
know I know I've been away for quite a
while and I did graduate dental school
so technically I'm a dentist now dr. Rob
and I'm not gonna make you guys call me
that or anything but I'm doing a
residency now at a hospital and I
started back in July so I'm going to be
continuing that until June and after
June hopefully I will find a place where
I could work in practice I have some
other things that I want to share with
you guys some updates that I'll probably
have in another video and I also have
some more tutorials that I want to teach
I'm definitely not leaving YouTube I'm
here to stay so I appreciate you guys
waiting for me and showing your support
and just inspiring me to keep going I
really enjoy the feedback and reading
your guys comments if you guys find some
cool ways to modify the wings of the
plane and videotape it definitely put it
in the video responses below and I might
feature it in my next video but once
again thank you very much for watching
and I'll see you guys next time just
right after fold and you could throw it
and it will glide pretty well oh no
ah